it's great to be joined today by will
McCaskill who is an associate professor
of philosophy at Oxford University one
of the progenitors of the social
movement of effective altruism which
encourages the use of evidence and
reason to do as much good as possible
will it's so great to have you on today
I appreciate it thanks so much for
having me on it's a pleasure
so let's see let's maybe start with why
would we even need a movement that wants
to focus altruism effectively in other
words what is often ineffective about
altruism and the social movements that
are inspired by it that would sort of
cause us to say hey we should really
think about how to be most effective in
our altruism yeah I think a lot of
people who are really kind of do good
and a really well-intentioned bit but
unfortunately the world so complex that
good intentions often aren't good enough
and there are many projects that people
undertake that not just like often
they're just squandering kind of most of
their resources or even can actually end
up doing harm as well and so that's why
it's crucial when we're thinking about
all the different problems we could be
facing all different things we could be
doing focus on I think not just what
does a little bit good but what does the
most good possible yeah one example I've
discussed with my audience when it comes
to the world of sort of international
aid is that there will many times be
this phenomena where you will have a cow
Western company that produces some kind
of product who will decide that they're
going to give a whole bunch of those
products to an impoverished population
in the developing world shoes would be
an example or whatever whatever the case
may be and that has obviously a positive
short-term effect people need shoes
people are better able to go to work if
they have shoes but it doesn't really do
anything to address the fact that for
for the long-term sustainability of that
population you're really going to need
to have sort of like a local shoe
industry and in fact you may be hurting
that in the long term by giving
everybody free shoes is that the type of
concern that you're dealing with is it
just one among many or tell us about
some of the other kind of maybe
misplaced forms of altruism yeah I mean
of shoes is a great example and in fact
we often think of just the charity give
directly is a kind of base standard by
which to compare of altruistic
activities where give directly simply
transfers cash to the poorest people in
the world saying well you know you know
best about how to spend money to help
yourselves we've got to have a really
high bar for thinking you know we know
better than you about what's most
important in your lives but yeah
unfortunately International Development
and do getting more generally just has
the history of many often quite
amusingly failed projects it's very help
so one example I like to use is the play
pump which is this a children's
merry-go-round that would double as a
water pump
so children would play in this
merry-go-round and using the force of
their play they would pump clean water
up to a tank that would provide the
needs for the village and this got tons
of awards at a time on a World Bank
development awards
it was lauded in the press but it was a
terrible idea I mean aside from health
and safety so kids would sometimes fall
off and break limbs sometimes vomit from
the spinning it was also just not a very
good pump so unlike a normal
merry-go-round that spins freely once
you've pushed it this would require
constant torque to pump up the water and
so kids would get very tired they
wouldn't want to play on this thing all
day and so it'd be left up to the
mothers or grandmothers of the village
to push this brightly pout brightly
colored play pump rounded lambda task
they'd often find humiliating and what's
more the kind of real kicker is just
that this humped far less water than the
very boiling but very functional is in
bad we hand pump that these pumps
sometimes replaced and yet it pumped
less water for three times the cost and
so despite you know seeming like this
amazing exciting invention it just
wasn't really what people actually
needed it wasn't the best way of helping
people and stories like this are just
all too common in in doing good better
you sort of lay out some of the
underlying principles of affect
altruism and if we were to sort of start
to develop not necessarily a guide but
maybe at least sort of like a framework
for thinking about how we can have the
greatest impact how important is the
concept of deal with the worst first in
other words the idea of finding the most
dire problem that we can solve and
trying to make improvements there is
that an important concept or is that one
that maybe can be a distraction from
figuring out the best way to do good
great I think it's an important concept
but crucially it's only one part of the
truth so we like to focus on problems
that are very important there is like
very great and scale that's kind of
direness you're talking about but then
also that are particularly tractable and
also that are particularly neglected so
problem might be really great in scale
which is very hard to fix so the fact
that we all die aging huge problem kills
hundred million people a year but maybe
not the most important thing to focus on
right now just because well such a hard
problem to solve scientifically and then
the collected Ness is perhaps the most
unintuitive of these criteria where it
could be the case that a problem is very
great in scale and there's actually
plenty of stuff you can do about it but
just there's already a lot of attention
being devoted to it and I give the
example of kind of disaster bully
disaster relief in this category
obviously providing funding after the
disaster is you know it's hugely
important and there often I want many
very good things you can do about it
though perhaps harder than some other
areas but disaster relief funding it
just gets a lot of funding compared to
what I would call ongoing natural
disasters like malaria tuberculosis
hiv/aids and that means that on the
margin with the additional funding that
you use it's not as effective as
something which might be in the news
less and therefore get less attention
yeah I mean you mentioned the news at
the very tail end there a lot of this
does seem to be media driven in the
sense that the ongoing crisis of all the
kids to use as a stereotypical example
all the kids dying of hunger in Africa
compared to an acute weather event for
example in the United States that kills
a dozen people or two dozen people and
the sort of imbalance of media coverage
relative to the to the harm that is done
that seems to significantly influence
how people choose to either spend their
time volunteering or make donations does
it not yes this is absolutely huge and
that means why you know people will want
to fund you know focus on something like
disaster relief rather than say
deworming which is one of our champion
causes where you know it just doesn't
make the news at least not until
recently but about a billion people
worldwide have intestinal worms in their
guts and this is probably the least sexy
cause area you could imagine but and it
doesn't kill as many people as other
diseases so it gets less attention but
it's phenomenally cheap to treat you can
cure children of intestinal worms for
less than 50 cents per person and that
there's at least some evidence for
thinking that that has long lasting
economic and educational impacts for
those children which you know which is
huge it seems that a lot of this is
related to this idea that one person who
dies is a tragedy which we all can sort
of connect with in the specific sense
but a statistic of 10,000 people dying
doesn't necessarily resonate with people
in a sort of coherent narrative sense
and in that way you could reduce the
imagine for example that the number of
kids dying from hunger in Africa is
10,000 a day a week but does you know
whatever number it is if you reduce that
to 8,000 you've just saved 2,000 people
but it's still not an incredible story
right because now the news story is only
8,000 died whether if we find housing
for the victims of a hurricane and we
see their faces and we know their names
that's incredibly powerful in a sense
yeah so I mean humans are just evolved
to identify and empathize with
individuals whereas when numbers get so
large it just it so it overwhelms us so
we do often
these you know campaigns that can raise
hundreds of thousands of dollars because
one person maybe one child has some
debilitating condition that needs a
large amount of money and obviously it's
great that people you know reach in to
reach out for their wallets to try and
fund that but at the same time that
amount of money could save the lives of
a hundred children elsewhere who are
just whose plight is less salient to us
and what effective altruism is about is
trying to just you know step back except
that that emotional impulse that empathy
is what's gonna drive us but then to any
use our ability to think and to reason
to then guide that wherever our efforts
will have the biggest impact in terms of
improving people's lives for people who
are doing the majority of their altruism
by donating to charities and nonprofits
what is the infrastructure you proposed
for evaluating where to donate and in
that sense you know throw out a few
things obviously the subject matter of
the nonprofit is important to many
people and many times people are making
contributions to nonprofits that are
working on something that they're
personally connected to but from the
point of view of for example looking at
the percentage of donated funds that get
to the beneficiaries as opposed to being
tied up in administrative cost is that
type of analysis the type that the
average person should be doing to figure
out where to donate or do you propose a
different infrastructure yeah so the
metric of how much is spent on overheads
versus programs
I just don't think is very helpful at
all interesting because you could have
it you could have a really you know a
really dumb program one you know what's
the play Punk for example and maybe had
very very low overheads and only 1%
overheads but if you've got 1% overheads
on what's not very good program you're
still just be not gonna be a very good
charity
in contrast perhaps you spend 30 percent
doing research monitoring and evaluation
identifying the very best places to help
and then you're funding something like
deworming where you're having this huge
impact perhaps a hundred times more a
thousand times more even than typical
ways of doing good well if you
getting a hundred ex on some other
charity taking 30% off of that even
though I would say that 30% is necessary
in the first place well that doesn't you
know you're still doing this far far
goods and far far more good than if
you've been focusing on a can a lesser
program and so for individuals what I'd
recommend actually is in general just
trying to follow advice and
recommendations or kind of experts that
we've and you know we've tried to build
up this infrastructure so just in the
same way as if you're investing your
money you wouldn't you know best advice
is not to do it yourself instead maybe
go with an index fund or go with good
financial advice we have a bunch of
experts who you know in total have spent
tens of thousands of hours trying to
work out what charities do the most good
and within the area of global health and
development that we've talked about the
most
I give well is the charity that really
produces outstanding research on this
topic and if you go with their
recommendations you can save a life to
just a few thousand dollars if you're
interested in other cause areas
effective altruism dorg we have a set of
funds that focus on either global health
and development or animal welfare or on
the long run future so rather than
trying to help people today to animate
ensure that human civilization goes as
well as possible for those centuries to
come and there you can donate to this
fund that then experts will redistribute
to the places that they think are going
to have the biggest impact absolutely
fascinating stuff we're going to link to
a lot of those organizations in the
description for the YouTube video for
the interview we've been speaking with
will McCaskill who's an associate
professor of philosophy at Oxford
University will so great to talk to you
I really do appreciate it thanks so much
for having me on